I'm going to use some physics to answer the question of whether or not Rapunzel really could
support someone's weight just with her hair.
So I'm going to make a few assumptions.
The first is that it's possible to grow your hair to be 20 meters long,
and that's a conservative estimate of what Rapunzel's length was.
Hair usually takes
one year to grow about 15 cm (5.9 inches)
So, to grow 20 meters of hair would usually take 133 years
That's if everything else goes well.
The current world record is about 5.5 m (18 ft),
And mine, probably a measly
1.3 meters (4.2 ft)? Something like that.
But, let's assume it's possible.
Now, Rapunzel's hair is going to weigh a lot
I found one estimate that twelve centimeters (4.7 inches) of hair would weigh
0.62 milligrams.
That works out to be 103 mg for 20m (65.5 ft) of hair.
Multiply that by 150000 hairs on an average blonde head,
and we end up with 15.5 kilograms (3.3 lbs) of hair.
Now let's look at some forces
Downwards, we have the force of gravity acting on the hair
that's going to be 155 Newtons.
Add the weight of say, a prince, and
take his mass to be 80 kilograms (176 lbs).
That gives us a total downwards force of
955 Newtons.
Now, there's actually no way that Rapunzel's neck would be able to withstand
that kind of force.
And in fact, one of the weakest components in this is going to the the bonds between
her hair and her scalp and connecting to the skull.
So... the hair would actually probably get ripped out there if all of that force is going straight to the roots.
However, that doesn't mean it's not possible to hold that weight.
Rapunzel just needs to hook her hair or tie it around something
to take that force directly off her neck and head.
If she can do that, then lifting a prince
shouldn't actually be a problem, because in fact,
human hair is incredibly strong.
Each strand of it can hold about 100 grams.
That's about one apple.
So, put together, for a hundred and fifty thousand strands,
human hair should be able to lift
15000 kgs (33069.3 lbs).
That's incredible and that's a casual 188 princes.